let's revisit the island or the universe
that only has a farmer and a builder in
it and let's think about a different
scenario let's think about a scenario
where they each start off with a lot of
physical currency or we're in our
universe that starts off with much more
physical currency than the last example
where the whole universe only had four
gold coins so let's say that the farmer
right over here starts off with and I'll
write down the number instead of drawing
the coins let's say he starts off with
five actually let me draw the coins
that's kind of fun so let's say he
starts off with with five gold coins and
the Builder also starts off with five
gold coins but entering into this year
the farmer is feeling pretty pessimistic
and so he goes to the Builder and he
tells builder look I just want the base
level of construction or maintenance or
whatever going on on my farm today I can
only afford one coin of business from
you or what you can do for one coin so
he gives that coin to the Builder now
the Builder is feeling pretty
pessimistic normally the farmer starts
off the year much better than that he
says this is clearly going to be a bad
year so I'm only going to buy my base
necessities for food so he goes to the
farmer says look all even though I have
you know he's not gonna tell the farmer
that he's hoarding all this cash but
he's going to say look farmer things are
bad business is bad I'm preparing for
the worst just give me the base minimum
cheapest simplest food you can that'll
keep me alive and so he only gives one
coin back to the farmer now imagine that
the money supply actually increases for
whatever reason the farmer digs around
in his backyard and finds some more gold
and then the Builder also while building
a building actually discovers a huge
chest of gold right over here but
they're still feeling pretty pessimistic
maybe they're just pessimistic people
and so the farmer despite this increase
in the money supply this gold that he
discovers he's like you know how how
frequently I'm going to discover gold
like that that was just a one-off thing
a bonanza that I just happened to run
into the business itself is pretty bad
so I'm and it was even worse last year
than it normally is so I'm going to
spend as little as possible so I'm going
to go to the Builder and I'm gonna say
look things things seems to only be
getting worse I can only afford half a
coin worth of
your of what you have to offer before
this base maintenance and the builders
thinking well gee you know that's even
worse than last year but I have all this
extra capacity I could be building so
much more I have people who aren't
working sure I'll take it I'll take your
half coin and I'll deliver that same
service I'll delete deliver the same
service for that half of a coin and so
he does it and so essentially his price
has gone down despite the fact that
there's more currency and so the Builder
even though he dug around and found all
this gold he's feeling even worse the
price of what he's offering has gone
down he's got even less revenue in total
and absolute gold coins now so when he
goes to the farm he's like look I need
to buy that base level of food otherwise
my family's going to starve but business
is worse than ever I'm so pessimistic he
doesn't even tell the farmer that he
discovered all of this and he's hoarding
all of this and so he says farmer I can
just afford half a coin verse worth of
stuff and the farmer says well I guess
so since the building prices have gone
down and I can buy more with that half a
coin and I have all of this surplus
labor and surplus capacity on my farm
sure I will take a half a coin for what
I for the same thing that last year I
took a full coin for so you see the
situation where deflation is occurring
even though the money supply has
increased and of course I'm exaggerating
things that normally if you had this
large of a bonanza and the money supply
people would start to get optimistic and
would start to spend money and it
probably would lead to deflation but the
main point here is to realize that it
isn't just driven by the absolute
quantity of the currency that's
important but just as important our
confidence and and what confidence
drives and that's specifically the
velocity of money the transactions of
money the higher the velocity that that
or or quantity matters but quantity
times velocity is what really drives the
the level of prices